première alerte donnée ici il est 21h 20
à poiseul 23h43 à seulement quelques
kilomètres ce bâtiment prend feu c'est à
mme annie lambert
enfin ce hangar brûle il est minuit
passé
les pompiers sont à nouveau en action
sur la commune de poison plus de mille
mètres carrés sont partis en fumée dans
la nuit de vendredi à samedi une série
d' incendies qui n'est malheureusement
pas la première dans le secteur de
baigneux les juifs en cinq ans 18
sinistre d'origine inconnue ont été
recensées par les agriculteurs
un climat de psychose s'installe petit à
petit tout le monde est sous pression
tout le monde un peu de mal à dormir je
pense tout le monde est suspicieux son
oiseau tous ceux qui voient passer
d'admis toutes les voitures de tout ça
va durer un mois deux mois puis après
ils ont tendance à se relâcher ce qui
est normal dans les autres content on
s'aperçoit qu'il n'ya pas ce même fait
même phénomène dans qu'il ait dit si les
exploitants n'ont donc pas de doute pour
la piste criminelle est la seule
possible et plus ça va plus le danger
grandi au bail met sa touche la maison
d'habitation
ça aurait pu faire des dégâts vraiment
énorme énorme énorme
la brigade de recherches de montbard
déjà en charge des investigations sur
les précédents incendies à d'ores et
déjà commencé à enquêter sur ce nouvel
épisode troublant des auditions sont en
cours et des expertises doivent être
effectués sur les différents lieux pour
tenter de déterminer s'il ya bien un
incendiaire qui sévit dans le secteur de
baigneux les juifs